the operation of the free market is so
essential
not only to promote productive
efficiency but even more
to foster harmony and peace among the
peoples of the world
forty years ago pbs of all networks gave
the libertarian economist milton
friedman hours in prime time for
free to choose an unapologetic take on
why capitalism was morally and
pragmatically superior to
socialism over the course of 10 hour
long episodes the nobel prize winner
laid out the pitfalls of protectionism
as consumers buying in an international
market the more
unfair the competition the better
espouse the virtues of school choice
how do you explain the fact that there
is no area of the free market no area of
the private market
in which the poor people who live in the
ghettos of our
major cities are as disadvantaged as
they are with respect to the kind of
schooling they can get
and explained why spending not taxes was
the real measure of the
burden that governments put on their
citizens if congress spends 50 billion
dollars more than it takes in
government spends 50 billion who do you
suppose pays that 50 billion
of course the arab sheiks aren't paying
it santa claus isn't paying it the tooth
fairy isn't paying it
in an era long before the web and
youtube democratized discourse friedman
showcased an assortment of
radical thinkers such as economist
walter williams
the minimum wage law has the effects of
saying that if you cannot produce 2.90
worth of goods an hour you don't deserve
a job and thomas seoul
to ascribe any status to any group of
people equality
inferiority superiority must necessarily
reduce freedom
and he subjected leading left-wing
intellectuals like democratic socialist
michael harrington
teachers union leader albert schenker
and political scientist
francis fox pivens to withering
criticism
of their ideas you've got to compare
something with something
will you tell me the alternative which
has improved a lot of the ordinary
people
what is the system which in your mind
has been successful
most people through most history have
lived in tyranny and misery it's only a
very tiny minority
at any time that have been able to
escape from it frida choose has been
translated into two dozen languages and
a companion book co-authored by milton
and his wife rose was a new york times
bestseller and a book of the month club
selection
the series was a response to the age of
uncertainty a 1977
pbs series hosted by harvard economist
john kenneth galbraith
a former ambassador to india who was a
leading spokesman
for big government liberalism age of
uncertainty was an attempt to begin to
use storytelling
as a way to reach people but it was a
dismal failure because
galbraith was terrible the tv series
just disappeared
but it's not like free the jews which is
just everywhere
40 years later the visionary producer
behind free to choose was robert
chitister a hardcore free marketer who
ran the pbs affiliate at erie
pennsylvania
and wanted to bring libertarian ideas to
mainstream audiences
back then he says programs about
capitalism and free enterprise were
almost always relentlessly hostile they
were
really much breaking attacks on
what was perceived to be abusive or
unsympathetic free market capitalism
where
profit was all that mattered in contrast
frida choose talked about capitalism in
upbeat positive terms stressing how it
helped individuals rather than exploited
them and how it brought about
cooperation
in a way that benefited the poor most of
all one of the reasons why i am in favor
of less government
is because when you have more government
industrialists take it over
and the two together form a coalition
against the ordinary worker and the
ordinary consumer
chitisser says that while the topic of
each episode was sketched out ahead of
time
friedman's comments were unrehearsed and
improvised his favorite quote of the
entire series comes in
episode 5 when friedman drew a
distinction between equal opportunities
and equal outcomes
if you promote free if you remove
arbitrary obstacles you open the way for
people to use their resources
you will end up in my opinion and i
think the empirical evidence is
overwhelmingly on this side
you will end up with both more free more
prosperity
but did friedman make any mistakes and
free to choose
his celebration of the free market
miracle in hong kong
is poignant to watch at the moment that
that city's freedoms are
under siege and before his death
friedman came to question his famous
axiom
that economic freedom in autocracy such
as china
would give rise inevitably to political
and cultural freedom
milton in a discussion close to near the
end of his life
indicated to me he said bob but i made a
mistake i was wrong
you have to have the fourth element you
have to have
rule of law you have to have law that
applies equally to everyone
and clearly that's what you see not
happening in china
at 83 an ailing from a long bout with
cancer
chitister is himself contemplating his
own mortality and how american society
has changed since free to choose aired
40 years ago he's proud that the program
remains popular online but
like friedman feels its analysis is
somewhat incomplete
power is really something we have to
factor into our thinking
the desire of humans to tell other
humans what to do
you couple that with equality and boy
you've got a recipe for
constant problems in defending
a classical liberal society forty years
later
free to choose the program bob chidister
created with milton and rose friedman
remains a powerful source
for optimism and hope about freedom and
the future
our freedom is in jeopardy but it by no
means has been completely destroyed and
i believe
i believe that there is a strong enough
component of freedom in our society
that we will be able to preserve it that
we're going to turn this trend back
we are going to cut government down to
size we're going to lay the groundwork
for a resurgence of that diversity
which has been the real product of our
free society